hey BuzzFeed we are the cast of Pokemon
to take the Pikachu I'm just a slip
I'm Ryan Reynolds I'm Catherine Newton
and we're about to do a BuzzFeed quiz
which Pokemon are you who's an
occupation you pursue in the Pokemon
universe readers that is information I
know
Catherine like I love their outfits okay
yes I think they're funny they're always
like you know they're just like funny it
part of the animated just like the
blocks you know I think I'm gonna
actually I joined Team Rocket Wow okay
and you I'm debating between gym leader
and trainer cuz the gym leader I feel
like has to only work with a certain
type elemental type is holy moly
detailed
Olympic trainer epic trainer guess I'm
gonna pick Pokemon breeder because
somebody's propagating species right so
I'm going in I'm going in for some
expertly lit French Pokemon and the next
question is what do you value the most
in others
loyalty humor intelligence honor passion
and the treatment in my answer already
it went really deep I feel like it took
a left yeah I thought we were gonna talk
more about who are you as a person
mine's empathy empathy is I think
sexiest quality any human being can have
you know he rocks
it should teach empathy in schools I
think I'm gonna say passion no I feel
like if you're not passionate about the
things that you do then what why bother
um I'm gonna pick loyalty because I'm an
only child and like loyalty like you
know it's great technically your parents
are kind of forced to be loyal to you
want to ruin your childhood like I'm
really loyal to right up right right
right
Psyduck and I are together forever it's
true yeah that's Jeffrey's your rider
guys will take a type of
to join your team fire grass water
psychic rock ghost where's the fairy
option I'm gonna pick ghosts I like I
like it like dark den Arijit bored I'm
loyal like I said so I picked psychic
because sign up is a psychic level up
I'm gonna go with grass because I have
allergies
yeah that doesn't that's very food it
does it they're gonna cut it out are you
going to pick one of the original three
Pokemon to join your team
Bulbasaur I have to take this word off
why thank you
I'm also going this fertile okay so
choose a special attack Thunderbolt ice
beam confusion energy ball fiery dance
sludge bomb specials oh I'm going with
under ball because Pikachu that's true
I'm gonna go with energy ball I'm gonna
just try confusion I feel like that's a
very special attack not only fiery dance
hi really here's money on a mission Oh
Oh flareon I have a huge Eevee tattoo on
my lower back
really tasteful piece I'm doing the
poori oh yeah I'm going flareon there
way don't know which way to pick okay
before you okay what kind of location
would you set up shop in the city the
country the jungle the desert and island
of beach fun country I'm gonna go to the
beach I wish it was like a forest outfit
but I do the double nice way good Kathy
watch system are you playing Pokemon on
intend of 64 Nintendo 3ds and hit the
switch Gameboy on my PC on my cell phone
right now I'm paying for someone go on
my cellphone
I gotta get a switch but I also can't
wait to get the new Pokemon sort of
Pokemon shield coming in Nintendo switch
later this year Atari it's not an option
I want a femaie Gameboy I used to sell X
is great but it just seems kind of sorry
not as aerodynamic as there may be
imagined well I got new too which is the
most powerful it is enjoy your
Jigglypuff this has been so much fun I
can't believe I got my answer and this
has been the cast of the Pokemon to take
Pikachu movie and we're did of quiz I
just want to jump in and just say that
this has been amazing for justice and
free Catherine I think this has really
been really fun something really special
for you transformative transfer be
honest I feel like I've just passed
through an episode of Oprah yeah I
learned a lot about myself so thank you
to look inward
[Music]